[Music]
at the end of the day I want to see the
number one contender fight the champ I
ride the fence I get the business side
from what they want to do and then I get
from a pure fighter standpoint I was
just about to say but I'm a hypocrite
because I was happy when Dan Henderson
got that shot against Michael Bisping
I'm like that wanna see or GSP it makes
no sense he site in Bisbee well the
problem with the GSP biz make fires it
ties up the division and when you have a
guy like Robert Whittaker who just ices
Jacare Holstrom
ice that's the best he's a killer
Whitakers a killer straight kills
straight killer
he's from the top three I like his
chance against anyone now Yoel Romero
such a freak son
maybe you you're a hundred percent right
that it's a hell of a fight
I mean do you see your Romero in
chocolate I don't even think you all
beat jock gray really you could really
give some of that fight to jock ray like
he remembers a split decision do you
have that one moment when we spawn and
jock ray with that spinning backfist
through it I'm on queer Bulova hooker
may Jacare look like a [ __ ] amateur
jazz [ __ ] and hocked them down even
out his backs like the [ __ ] outta here
Oh vehicles yeah I feel like Whitaker's
better now than ever and I think he's
only 25 or 26 66 I think someone he's no
no older than that he's a young buck and
he's coming up strong and he's another
one that went from 170 to 185 and
improved tremendously soon as he stopped
cutting the radical amount of weight all
sudden dude's got vitality and power
it's not in the big Johnson fight the
Bronson fight was serious that was a big
wake-up call to people because yes
Ronson was putting it on him well
Bronson rushed at him chin first and I
was like oh my god how's this gonna work
out and he covered up you smart compose
and then just yeah it was Australian
[ __ ] shuffle
I'm a fan now and I thought he was gonna
lose that fight and I'm like oh that's
my guy I will sit down I'm down man and
see all the Crocodile Dundee memes no
come on man a dude from Australia fights
that dude who calls himself to alligator
she that's a great book
now this is a knife [ __ ] that's a
naughty knife yeah man Kirsten he's the
new hotness in that division needs some
hotness like the new blood I love when
there's new blood she's like fun yeah
don't need now we need that a
heavyweight in light heavyweight light
heavyweight we're like yeah I guess you
know what DC John Key is just by each
other every other weekend
[Applause]
[Music]